يبدو ان الشعور بالتعاسه والحزن لا يتعلق
باللحظات التي يمر بها الانسان بشكل فردي
المساله تتعلق بالحاله العامه للعقل
البشري وذلك بحسب دراسه حديثه نشرت في
مجله بيترا الالمانيه حددت اكثر المراحل
العمريه عسل نتائج الدراسه تقول انه بغض
النظر عن الحاله الاجتماعيه المهنيه
والاكاديميه ينخفض منحنى السعاده في سن
معينه ويبقى هذه الدراسه يصل الاشخاص في
اواخر الاربعنات من العمر الى اعلى
مستويات التعاسه وتحديدا يفصل الاشخاص الى
هذا المستوى في الدول الصناعيه في السنه
السابعه والاربعين عاما وفي البلدان
الناميه يصل الى ادنى مستوى من السعاده
عند 48 عاما
[موسيقى]
دراسه بتقول انه في اواخر الاربعينات يصل
الانسان الى مستويات
الطبيعيه
التزامات كثيره جدا
عملناها مجنونه ومغامرات غير طبيعيه فهي
دائما بيعتبره احسن مرحله هتكون الانسان
فيه سعيد لما يعمل الثلاث اشياء هذولا اقل
التزاما اكثر جراه اكثر مغامره
اذا بناءا على اللي عم
بتقول ما عنده اولاد شغل منيح يعني هو
الاسعد
دكتور دراسه تقول انه لما يوصل الانسان
الى مرحله الاربعينيات يصير يفكر فيها
اهداف جديده ويفكر يعيش حياه سعيده بعيدا
عن مشاكل الحياه اليوميه هل هي ازمه منتصف
العمر ممكن تسميه
42 انت بتصير معناها هذه المرحله دائما
احنا بنقول في وقفه مهم جدا في الحياه
الوفاه تبعت ال 40 او ال 42 المهم اللي
بعد من الاربعين هي وقفه بسيطه جدا بيكون
قاعد ساعات انا طبعا بس في ناس ما بتعملها
دلوقت بيكون قاعد بيبلش يفكر انا متجوز
عندي اولاد طب انا اولادي كيف مبسوطين انا
دخلتهم هم كذا كذا
حسب نفسه على المرحله اللي عاش في حياته
هي هي اهم اهم مرحله في حياتنا بقى من اهل
المرحله اللي بعد ال 40 لان احنا خلاص
وصلنا الى بعد منتصف العمر ودخلنا في
مرحله التزامات كثير فهي هذه كثير في هذا
الوقت اللي بتصير فيه المشكله انك انت
بتصير بدنا نعرف انهي مرحله كله في ناس
بتفكروا بيقول لك انا احلى مرحله في حياه
الطفوله انت شوف فاكر من الطفوله انا فاكر
الطفوله كنا بنلعب كنا بنعمل طب والمراهقه
لا كانت صعبه وهكذا فهي كيف تتربط احنا
السعاده او المراحل الجميله اللي كان فيها
ذكريات جايه
[موسيقى]